at the end of president trump's first
term
he says hopefully at the end of that
term president trump established
something called the 1776
commission the 1776 commission sought
to overturn the
historical revision that attempts to
reframe our country's history
and attack the very foundations of our
country so the 1776 commission
seeks to undermine the 1619 project
which
attempts to cast our country in a very
negative light and joe biden
now that he is president has decided in
the spirit of unity
and healing and moving our country
forward he's going to completely scrap
the 1776 commission look in the weeks
ahead
i'll be reaffirming the federal
government's commitment to diversity
equity and inclusion
and accessibility building on the work
we started
in the obama biden administration that's
why
i'm rescinding the previous
administration's harmful ban on
diversity and sensitivity training
and abolished the offensive counter
factual 1776 commission
unity and healing must begin with
understanding and truth
not ignorance and lies he's going to
get rid of the offensive 1776 commission
he is going to permit sensitivity
training also known
as re-education all in the spirit of
unity and healing well if the 1776
commission which sees our country as
good
is offensive and untrue then i guess our
president thinks that our country
is wicked to the core he is not the 1776
president
he's the 16-19 project president i'm
michael knowles
the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from john helton who
says
if your insurrection lasts more than
four hours consult your doctor
immediately great advice from chuck
schumer that's true that's the
that's always got to be the disclaimer
that he puts
on on all of his political advice it's
true you don't want those insurrections
to last more than four hours
as actually as far as i can tell the
capital hill riot did not last more than
four hours
and the blm and antifa riots lasted more
than four months so
just just important to keep in mind when
you are comparing
those things when you want to comparison
shop by the way you got to check out
select quote
select quote comparison shops up highly
rated companies including
prudential banner life and mutual of
omaha among others
to find you the company with the best
rates for example select quote could
find a 35 year old man a
half million dollar policy for under 19
a month
that is less than a dollar a day a cup
of coffee costs more than that cost a
lot more than that actually depending on
where you go
select quotes breakthrough technology
allows them to quickly match you
with the best insurance company to find
your best policy plus the quotes are
free
you know i just recently became a father
and so i
i was thinking about this a little bit
more it's just about peace of mind the
one thing that really i think could keep
me up at night
is thinking that you might leave your
family without uh without anything
if if god forbid something happened
don't
let that happen to you just be
responsible do the right thing
give yourself peace of mind let select
quote save you time and money
get your free quote at selectquote.com
today that is selectquote.com for your
free quote
don't put it off protecting your family
one
more day selectquote.com get full
details on the example policy at
selectbook.com
commercials your premium could vary
depending on your health issuing company
and other factors
not available in all states great way to
find yourself some terrific
insurance go to select quote
joe biden there's no other way to put it
he is the 16-19
project president broadly speaking
without getting too into the weeds on
the new york times 1619 project in the
1776 commission
the 1776 commission says that america
broadly is good that is the framing of
american history that it begins with
the 1619 project explicitly it says it
right on the first page
seeks to reframe american history
to cast it in the negative light so
according to the 1619 project
america is essentially rotten
evil corrupt to the core
joe biden has picked aside in his first
days in office
the guy has been in office now for like
seven days i guess today it is it is
coming up on a week that joe biden has
been in office
and he's already he's not just pushing
these kind of smaller less ambitious
policies
he is instituting sensitivity training
which is a politically correct euphemism
for
politically correct brainwashing right
for re-education
classes and part and parcel of that is
he's going to revise american history
and and this ties in with an issue that
we were talking about yesterday
i have to revisit it because i got in so
much trouble
for my views and i didn't even get in
trouble with the left i got in trouble
really
with conservatives who are who think
that i'm too conservative or something
this issue of of kicking out andrew
jackson from the 20
bill and putting harriet tubman on there
i
saw a lot of conservatives yesterday who
were tweeting out
as if to win the applause of the left
and they were saying listen leftists i
haven't seen a single conservative
who isn't totally on board with kicking
out andrew jackson and putting harriet
tubman on the 20.
please show me the one conservative okay
here it is i'm the one conservative you
found me
i guess you guys weren't weren't looking
too hard because here i am
and i don't think it's just me by the
way i think a lot of americans
don't want to kick andrew jackson off
the 20 bill
they don't want to castigate jackson and
say he was an awful rotten terrible
person
and jackson really is just he's just an
easy target
but this this campaign which comes from
the 1776 project
and affiliated groups seeks to
overturn all of our venerated forebears
it's not just going to stop at jackson
it's going to go to jefferson and
washington and lincoln it already is
they're already toppling statues of
those guys
i think there are a lot of americans who
feel that way and i i understand
that there are many conservatives who
really want to prove to the left that
they're not racist but i
i have to promise you that
the left already thinks you're a racist
and they also don't care
whether or not you're a racist if you
are
what is racism racism is the unjust
discrimination against people
and antagonism of people on the basis of
their race it is wrong
because it is an offense against human
dignity that's it
if you're not that then don't worry
about it you don't need to prove
anything to the left you won't be able
to prove anything to the left it's very
pitiful to try to prove these things to
the left
they are not going to start liking you
because you're saying mean things about
andrew jackson
they don't like you okay sorry
pretending to love the harriet tubman 20
bill is not going to save you from the
gulags
be they digital or otherwise it's just
so lame this is why we lose every
cultural issue
this is it guys i you know when we look
back
on all the crazy politically correct
cultural changes that have happened
we say why didn't conservatives stand up
i mean let's use the
gendered bathrooms for a second the you
know boys can use the girls room or
whatever
we said what how on earth do we get to
this place why didn't we stand up
well the reason that we got to this
place is because
every time the issue was actually hot
actually every time was actually
happening conservatives who wanted to go
along to get along said oh who cares
it's not a big deal
they did they did it even with the
bathrooms there were many conservatives
who said oh it does
who cares it affects very few people
let's
it's fine if some if some boys are
confused and think they're girls let's
just it's fine let's not
i don't want people to think i'm a bigot
or this phobe or that phobe so let's
let's just not touch it we're going to
redefine marriage
well let's i don't want people to think
i'm a bigot of some so let's just let's
not touch it
we're going to redefine whole
norms in society let's not touch it
we're going to institute new
legal racial discrimination in the form
of affirmative action well
let's i don't want to who cares it's not
a big deal it only affects a few
slots at a university it only affects a
few jobs please let's let's go along to
get along
this is the same thing guys do not
do not tell me who cares
when we say that these cultural issues
don't matter like the harriet tubman 20
bill doesn't matter we give away the
whole
game when we say oh forget about that
let's just talk about the economy
the cultural issues not only do they not
not matter the cultural issues pretty
much are the only thing that matters
what profited if a nation
to have gdp through the roof
but to lose its whole culture that's
not that's not what matters and
conservatives need to shake themselves
out of this very silly idea
that all that matters is tax cuts and
bumping up gdp a little bit
so that jeff bezos can buy a new yacht
that's not what matters you know what
matters
preserving our traditions preserving our
love of country
preserving our local communities
preserving our venerated
figures and forebears and rituals that's
what matters
and it'd be nice to get low taxes too
but that is going to come downstream
okay the the economic policy is going to
come downstream
of that cultural policy
when you say it doesn't matter who cares
20 bill doesn't matter well
you know it matters to me it matters i
think to a great number of conservatives
so good if it doesn't matter then let it
go
right if it doesn't really matter then
fine then we won't change it
because you're you're the one who wants
to change it leftist
and i'm the one who doesn't want to
change it and you say it doesn't matter
and no one cares and i say i care
so good let it go oh they're not going
to let it go though because they do care
and they care for a reason because they
know that the framing of our nation
in the minds of its citizens is the
whole game
it will utterly transform the politics
that's why joe biden is so eager
to cancel the 1776 commission and to
castigate it as
offensive offensive to to love your
country
that will not get us
unity but the left of course does not
want unity
the left does not want unity at all they
want
more and more division we talked about
this a little bit yesterday
after chris cuomo was uh
like a like some sort of demon you know
loving it while this child was talking
about how he turned his dad into the fbi
after his dad went to the steel stop the
steel rally in dc
and chris cuomo said yeah go on tell me
more about this what society
what the left does is it wants to break
down
every single traditional institution so
it goes after the church
it goes after voluntary associations it
goes after specifically the family
because for the left the essential unit
of society is the individual
and some libertarians buy into this
stuff too but it's just silly and
wrong and contrary to human nature in
fact
as conservatives understand the
fundamental social institution is the
family
that's the unit we're not born
free-floating atoms were born
with from a mother and a father who
loved each other were born out of that
love
ultimately we're born out of the love
that our creator has for us and we have
loyalty to them and we have duty to them
and we have obligation to them
and the left has to break all of that up
so unity isn't going to work
what they have to do is they have to
break down the country all the
institutions all the churches
all of the families that has been
at the heart of revolutionary movements
from the beginning and then they bind us
all back together as we're all
individuals and then
our best relationship we have is with
the state barack obama ran on this he
called it the life of julia in 2020 they
scrubbed it from the internet because it
was so creepy
but that is the kind of unity that
they're talking about
we have to be strong one great way to be
strong by the way
is to check out beachbody i want my
beachbody you should check out yours too
it's been a while since i had exercised
so i've started exercising again and it
hurts a lot but it doesn't matter no
pain no gain
beachbody on demand offers over 1500 at
home workouts plus nutrition plans
so no matter what your goals are they
have a program
that will help you build and keep
healthy habits
you know i had not worked out for about
eight months seriously i was writing my
book i was
i had the kid coming on the way and then
i just decided i want to get my new
beach body
so i started working out again
physically it kind of hurts but it feels
good too it feels good
to be more active be more in shape
beachbody is a great way to do it it's
great for all fitness levels
whether you're a beginner or whether
you're a sort of hulking adonis like i
am you can go check it out they even
have workout calendars and progress
trackers you can do them as quickly as
10 minutes a day
that don't require extra equipment so
for anybody you don't you don't have any
excuses
you can look at the workouts on your
computer smart tv
tablet smartphone roku apple tv
chromecast i could go on and on and on
right now listeners to the michaelano
show can try it absolutely free
it is time to get in shape get a special
free trial no obligation membership
text knowles 2 30 30 30. you will get
full access to the entire platform all
the workouts nutrition information and
support totally free
text knolls to 30 30 30. go
be strong get your beach body
one way that some misguided senators
are trying to give us unity is by
impeaching the president
so mitt romney who i've been
uncharacteristically nice to recently
because he's been saying some halfway
decent things
now that he's in the senate minority and
it doesn't matter and he can
sort of mouth off and pretend to be
conservative however mitt romney is
reverting back to his old ways
he was just on chris wallace's sunday
show
and he says very very important for the
purpose of unity
to impeach the ex-president we're
certainly going to have a trial
i i i wish that weren't necessary but
the the president's conduct with regards
to the call the secretary of state
raffensburger in georgia
uh as well as the incitation towards the
insurrection
uh that led to the attack on the capital
uh calls for a trial and uh
uh you know if we're going to have uh
unity in our country i think it's
important to recognize the need for
accountability uh for truth and justice
so i think there will be a trial and i
hope it goes as quickly as possible but
that's up to the council
on both sides free for unity
we're going to have to impeach the
ex-president something we've never done
in this country
something that would be so unprecedented
after a bitterly contested presidential
election
where many of the rules of the election
and the safeguards for election
integrity were just completely thrown
out in the weeks and months before the
election places like
pennsylvania notably where they violated
the state constitution
to take away those safeguards by
instituting widespread unsolicited
mail-in votes that sort of
so you're telling me after all of that
the way you're gonna have unity
is by taking an unprecedented action and
impeaching an ex-president
of course not listen to the language so
vague truth and justice
now i totally support truth and justice
but notice how vague he's being about it
he's not making those connections it's
all
abstractions it's all out there romney
is not the only person calling for this
there are other republicans prominent
republicans
who are calling for this now
one of the most prominent republicans
doing this is megan mccain on the view
and i'm i'm not going to beat up on
megan mccain for calling for the
impeachment
mainly because donald trump was very
mean to her dad and so
i get it you know i sort of understand
why she might not like the guy
but listen listen to megan's argument as
to why we need to impeach the
former president donald trump i'm a
lifelong conservative unlike a lot of
these heretics i mean i was
born into this raised into it it's my
whole entire life
and in all ways and i truly at the
bottom of my soul i think as all of you
know i
i believe in the principles i was raised
on it is very difficult for me to come
on this show right now because i've
always prided myself on having my finger
on the tenor of what's going on in
conservative circles even when i didn't
agree with trump
i i you know i'm not a squoosh i'm not
someone who went full
brainwashed lincoln project that
everything that's conservative is a
bastion of evil and i must reject it and
atone myself
i'm not that kind of republican or
conservative but right now
i cannot defend this i believe president
trump should be impeached i believe we
have to take a stand and have a fine
line
about what is acceptable for a president
to do or not he incited a riot
people got violent people died full stop
okay so as i said i'm not i'm not going
to go after really the the substance
here because
you know if trump were were as tough on
my father as he was on megan's father uh
maybe i'd
feel differently about the man uh
obviously megan mccain and i disagree on
on impeachment
and uh and i suppose on trump more
broadly
but i want to focus in on on one word
she said
president president she said it's very
important to impeach
president trump there is no president
trump
president trump is gone there is former
president trump and sometimes in this
country we refer to former presidents as
president
but we're actually not supposed to as a
matter of etiquette
you really shouldn't refer to former
presidents as mr president
or president bush or president clinton
because there's only one president
there's only and it's it actually does
get to we we do it to be polite i've
i've done it myself
but as a matter of republican virtue
lower case r there's only one president
at one time there's only one
governor at one time you really
shouldn't
to be polite we sometimes say you know
governor huntsman or governor
pataki or but really you shouldn't
there's only one
and the constitution does not establish
a process to impeach ex-presidents
just to impeach the president that is
why by the way
at this alleged impeachment trial the
chief justice
is not going to preside the chief
justice only presides according to the
constitution
at an impeachment trial when you impeach
the president
but we're not unless unless it's a bait
and switch and this whole thing is just
cocaine mitch's big ruse to convince
democrats that they're impeaching trump
but then
accidentally they end up impeaching
biden that would be hilarious and i
wouldn't put him past mr cocaine he is a
slippery one
but unless that happens chief justice
can't be there
now you might say well michael we've
we've impeached ex-judges before
which is true there we talked about this
a little bit on on the verdict podcast
with senator cruz
there have been times that that
ex-officials have been impeached
according to various laws
but the president is no ordinary
official an impeachment trial in the
senate is no ordinary impeachment
it is laid out the process is laid out
explicitly
in the u.s constitution and the
constitution
provides no route to impeach a former
president
rand paul who has been extraordinarily
impressive recently
just came out and gave a fiery speech
about
the farce that that whole process has
become
the constitution says the president vice
president and all civil officers of the
united states
shall be removed from office on
impeachment for
and conviction of treason bribery or
other high crimes and misdemeanors
article 1 section 3 clause 6 states
when the president of the united states
is tried the chief justice shall preside
as of noon last wednesday donald trump
holds none of the positions
listed in the constitution he is a
private citizen
the presiding officer is not the chief
justice nor does he claim to be
his presence in the chief justin's
absence chief justice's absence
demonstrate that this is not a trial of
the president but of a private citizen
therefore i make a point of order that
this proceeding
which would try a private citizen and
not a president a vice president
or civil officer violates the
constitution
and is not in order you tell him rand
absolutely true
and his speech was not
technically persuasive in that
they they took a vote yesterday in the
senate to
either throw out the impeachment trial
completely or to go on with the
impeachment trial
and unfortunately it was determined
after that vote that they would go on
with the impeachment trial so in that
sense rand paul's speech was not
persuasive
but in the most important sense it was
persuasive
because the vote was 45
senators voting against
continuing this impeachment trial if you
have 45 senators
you get these 45 republicans to vote
against
the impeachment trial then what you are
showing
broadly is that the democrats don't have
the votes for impeachment
it's not just a simple majority to
convict the president he's already been
impeached in the house
it's not just to convict the
ex-president i'm sorry he's already been
impeached in the house you need what
two-thirds
to convict in the senate they don't have
that
so it's dead on arrival
and mitch mcconnell made that point
himself
if the
trial is not going to result in a
conviction then
it's a complete waste of the senate's
time and frankly for that for that
matter
i'm all for it i want to waste the
senate's time
under the biden administration when when
the democrats have unified government
i want evidence to be presented
from the trump side i want i want
president trump
it's going to be a little tricky because
you've got to massage some of the
squishy republicans
i want the trump team at this
impeachment trial to
go out and present all of the evidence
of voting irregularities
of changing election laws right before
the election to benefit democrats
of violating state constitutions might
only be tangential to the case
but i totally want that and i want
people for at least some time to refer
to president trump right if they're
impeaching him i guess he's the real
president i guess he's the legitimate
president right
i think we could have a lot of fun with
that now that it's pretty clear
democrats are not going to convict and
and by the way if you are in a position
where you're the only president who's
ever been impeached twice
and they never convict you and they've
been trying to undermine you since you
first ran for office and the incumbent
spied on your campaign to try to prevent
you from ascending to the office in the
first place
that is not a mark of shame the left
wants to pretend that
double impeachment is a mark of shame
when the
the powers that are impeaching you are
so corrupt
it's a badge of honor president trump
should be uh very very happy about that
and it shows you by the way these
conservatives these republicans were
coming out now against impeachment
maybe they're doing it because it's
their judgment and that's the best
lights they can follow
but i think they also see that the
republican base is not going to tolerate
a vote for conviction
nor should they the left is coming at
all of us right now do you know they
even kicked off
our friend mike lindell they kicked him
off of twitter
they did so the best way i think to get
back at them is to go buy a mypillow
there has never been a better or more
important time
to go check out my pillow you know mike
lindell he's a great conservative guy
i i have often said i would buy mike
lindell's products even if they weren't
great
they are the best pillows i have ever
used they don't go flat you can wash and
dry them as many times as you want
they're just amazing
simple extraordinarily high quality for
a limited time my pillow is offering
their premium my pillows for their
lowest price ever you can get a queen
size premium my pillow
regularly 69.98 for only 29.98 that's a
40
savings the kings are only five bucks
more the left is really going after mike
they're really going after my pillow
because he's an outspoken conservative
and
and he just happens to have some of the
best product out there
and certainly in terms of pillows in
terms of his
field his his product you can't beat him
go over there right now support mike
lindell mypillow.com click on the radio
listeners square
there you will find not only this
amazing offer but also deep discounts
on all my pillow products including the
geez at dream sheets
the my pillow mattress topper and my
pillow towel sets or you can call 800
651 1148 use promo code
dailywire you should go check it out for
yourself
also by the way earlier this month we
released
our first movie run hide fight
exclusively
for daily wire numbers you can catch it
over at dailywire.com you know
the the critics hated this movie because
it's not politically correct
so they gave it like a zero percent
score on rotten tomatoes they gave it
like a negative score pretty much on
rotten tomatoes
but the audience gave it i think a 93
score
that's with over 2000 reviews in head on
over if you're not a daily wire member
yet
you can watch the movie on our website
on our streaming apps at apple tv and
roku
right now you'll save 25 if you use
promo code rhf
that is for run hide fight use that code
rhf at dailywire.com save 25
we'll be right back with a lot more
there is some more good news coming out
of the continued persecution of donald
trump they try and they try and they try
we now know that the senate almost
certainly will not convict him they just
don't have the votes
now the supreme court threw two lawsuits
out which accused
donald trump of violating the emoluments
clause of the constitution
which now ends a four-year legal battle
over the former
president's businesses so
the the accusation here is that donald
trump was enriching himself in office
now of course he wasn't
he lost a lot of money he didn't accept
a salary to be president
and his business has lost a lot of money
because leftists attacked the people
that were doing business with him
and they used legal mechanisms as well
to try to take away his ability to make
money in his family's ability to make
money okay
well the watchdog group citizens for
responsibility and ethics in washington
or crew decided to file one of these
emoluments lawsuits
the day after trump was inaugurated back
in 2017
attorneys general of dc and maryland
brought similar lawsuit in june of that
same year
and now it's over so that that attempt
to persecute the president
also out and then even better
beyond all the trump stuff there's even
better news coming out of the senate
mitch mcconnell has now come out and
announced
that one of the greatest fears
that we all had if democrats got unified
government
is not going to come true one of the
maybe the single
biggest fear was that democrats would
kill
the filibuster and they had promised
that they were going to kill the
filibuster so we had to take them
seriously
when they were saying they would do this
why did it matter if they killed the
filibuster
filibuster is not in the constitution it
hasn't existed for the entire history of
the u.s senate
because what the filibuster does is it
slows down legislation
and it requires longer deliberation
and it permits senators to hold up
radical legislation so
if you have the filibuster you can
prevent the most radical policies
if you kill the filibuster then all of a
sudden democrats can add dc and puerto
rico estates
they can pack the supreme court they can
do all the scary things they wanted to
do
mitch mcconnell announces quote today
two democratic senators publicly
confirmed they will not vote
to end the legislative filibuster they
agree with president bidens in my view
that no senate majority
should destroy the right of future
minorities of both parties to help shape
legislation
the legislative filibuster was a key
part of the foundation beneath the
senate's last
50 50 power-sharing agreement in 2001.
with the with these assurances i look
forward to moving ahead with a power
sharing agreement modeled on that
precedent
so part of the reason that mcconnell was
able to work this out
and prevent killing the filibuster is
because
the democrats don't have an outright
majority
in the senate right it's 50 50 right now
in the u.s senate
but kamala harris vice president can
serve
as that tie-breaking vote in the senate
under the constitution
so they've got this kind of bare sort of
majority but it's a little tricky
and it really matters when you figure
out who's going to make committee
appointments who's going who's going to
run
the senate because the majority leader
has so many
additional privileges so mcconnell comes
out and he says okay we'll do a power
sharing agreement it'll be that's all
fine
but you've got to agree not to kill the
filibuster biden
signals he's willing to do that because
biden right now is governing through
executive order anyway and he's
governing through
the bureaucratic state and this this is
why we shouldn't celebrate too much that
we've preserved the senate
and the legislature i mean that's going
to prevent a lot of radicalism
but don't forget in this country we are
not governed
by the system that the constitution
establishes
at least not directly and not in any
really recognizable way
the the body that really governs us that
really writes most of the laws that
affect our lives
it's not the house it's not the senate
it's the
administrative state it's the
bureaucracy you call it the deep state
you call it the executive agencies
whatever you want to call it
and they are still working unperturbed
these are the egghead technic rats who
come out and then one day they say
okay you've you've all got to wear masks
and then they say you shouldn't wear
masks then they say you got to wear two
masks and then they say you got to jump
up and down on a pogo stick and put a
doughnut on your head
and we just go along with it and they
write all those little regulations and
they really do have teeth a lot of those
regulations
and the courts defer to the agencies to
interpret their own statutes
so while the bureaucracy is still
running roughshod over our
constitutional order the media are
backing them up
i actually have to say you know how much
i hate to say i told you so
we covered for many many months we've
covered the masks which i've said from
the beginning are extremely stupid
and some people disagreed with me at the
beginning now i think everybody agrees
with me
then then just the other day they said
that there's
there's a new rule everyone's got to
start wearing
two masks and i thought about this for a
second i said wait uh
first of all you told us all not to wear
masks then you told us we had to wear
masks then
now you're telling us to wear two masks
i'm no scientist i'm no expert but i
think pretty soon
they're going to be telling us to wear
three masks right i believe i said this
on the show
yesterday or the day before well
tuning in to cnbc you can see former fox
news
anchor shepard smith comes out gives a
great big ol report on the efficacy
the genius of wearing three masks
since the start of the pandemic experts
have urged us to do
three things wash our hands maintain
social distance and wear a mask
all the time not when you feel like it
all the time when you're not eating and
drinking
but now the experts say with these
variants it's time to double up and
where to
this morning dr fauci and deutsche
endorse the idea on the today show
okay fine so fauci comes out and
supports the double masks i do want to
correct shepard smith here
he said that the experts told us to wear
masks from the beginning they didn't
tell us to wear masks from the beginning
they actually explicitly told us not to
wear masks from the beginning
fauchi said it was stupid to wear masks
and wouldn't do anything
and the surgeon general of the united
states said in all caps
multiple exclamation points stop buying
masks people so
shep got that completely wrong but fine
afterward then they said we all have to
start wearing masks
then they continue with their brilliant
report
experts say you can double up with a
tight weave
fabric mask for added protection now
virginia tech researchers found that
doubling up these cloth masks
increases the efficacy from 50 to 75
percent
a three layer mask could block up to 90
percent of the particles
and if you're layering your mask the
disposable surgical mask goes on first
and then the tight fitting fabric mask
goes right over the top
and then you can put the burka over your
head
and then you won't have any particle
come at you at all and you'll be wearing
a burlap sack
and then then we'll finally be safe then
we can get back to normal
when we're all covered not just in full
niqab but full burqa
then we're all back to normal here in
america follow the science
now you know i'm i'm not a obviously i'm
not a scientist
in a certain sense i guess i'm an expert
scientist but i you know i don't have
a fancy white lab coat i don't have some
sinicure at some
administrative agency but and just hear
me out
if the the one and then the two
and then you do the three what it
sh should we just sh should we quadruple
mask
is that because because that lady on
shepard smith show
says that two masks is 75
effective now what does that mean
effective i don't know
it's just a number you know from some of
the geniuses with their spreadsheets
and then three masks is 90 effective
so by my mic that's a fifteen percent
increase so by my calculation four masks
would be a hundred and five percent
effective
and i don't wanna be too ambitious here
five masks right follow me that would be
120
effective can you imagine how much
healthier you would be
you'd be 20 healthier than you are right
now man you
i don't know you could live to be 110 at
that point
so i'm going to keep trying to work out
my theory of masks it seems that the
the fouchy scientific technocratic
theory of masks
keeps changing day by day but i'm going
to keep working out mine too i'm going
to come in here tomorrow i'm going to
have 20 masks on my face
i'm going to be the healthiest man in
america
the the other reason i wanted to mention
this little segment from shep smith's
new show at cnbc
is i i was reminded watching this
just what losers conservatives are just
what
what losers we are how stupid we are
shepard smith was the main
daytime anchor at the putatively
conservative cable news
channel the cable news channel
for years and he's a huge
lib and he was always a huge lib
cnn does not do that cnn does not make
first of all they don't hire any
conservative not one not one single
conservative
does cnn have on staff
certainly they don't make the
conservative
the anchor of their daytime news
programming
msnbc does not have one single
conservative not one on staff
those those cable networks have some
kind of like squishy people that
they're like kind of like joe
scarborough right who's a liberal
but he pretends to be a conservative you
think of an anna navarro who is a
liberal
everything she does advances the liberal
cause
but she kind of but she goes on and her
chiron says she's a conservative right
so
they have those people who pretend but
they're not actually the thing
shepard smith actually is a huge lib
and we conservatives we say oh no look
we have to we got to put the liberals on
all the time
the real liberals why why do we have to
do that
why why are we playing by a completely
different set of rules
that is not particularly moral not
particularly ethical it's not as though
we can appeal to some higher
moral principle here as to why we do
this as to why we promote a bunch of
insane progressivism on our platforms
but we do we do it's so lame
it gets back to the store i keep coming
back to the story
of the harriet tubman 20 bill kicking
out andrew jackson
because it because it relates to this
primary
left-wing campaign of trying to reframe
american history and we just go along
with it we just say oh yeah totally
no yeah andrew jackson he's bad and
jefferson he's bad too you know in
washington he wasn't soaked radio and
slaves and
yeah no american history it's bad but
but it's not the worst thing in the
world i don't we just keep we keep
negotiating against ourselves
and we keep gobbling up liberal premises
it's just
so lame meanwhile
meanwhile we're up against the entire
liberal establishment the entire edifice
that involves the bureaucracy as we've
noted and the now elected government
and the media certainly
in hollywood and tech and education
i i was watching a little clip
certainly not the whole show but i was
watching george stephanopoulos
you know the ex clinton communications
director white house communications
director
clinton's hatchet man who then becomes
the totally objective serious
news anchor at a mainstream
network television network not just a
cable network but an actual network
network
george stephanopoulos so he's previewing
his show
on abc and they're playing clips and one
of the clips they want to get to
is chuck schumer's speech about the
insurrection take a look take a listen
to their
their version of chuck schumer's speech
america's 46th president confronts
multiple crises
as the senate prepares to try a former
president for the first time
senators will have to decide if they
believe
donald john trump incited the
insurrection
is that what he said hold on i i know we
played that clip yesterday on the show
did he say senators will have to decide
if donald john trump incited the
insurrection
is that what let's just go i think we
still have it in the queue from from
yesterday
what did chuck schumer actually say
senators will have to decide
if they believe donald john donald john
trump
incited the erection insurrection
against the united states oh
right that's what he said oh that's a
little different isn't it
stephanopoulos he didn't play that clip
he had his editors go in
and manipulate the video
not not it would seem just for clarity
because
the word erection took one second two
seconds it's not like
it's not as though they needed to cut it
down for timing
he cut it down to make chuck schumer
look better
because our state-run tv for the liberal
dominant regime in the united states
would make kim jong-un blush
it would make xi jinping blush
it's oh he'd be embarrassed he'd say
gosh guys we're being a little
transparent being a little on the nose
here
that's what we have in the united states
that is the regime we're up against
and we conservatives we just go along
with it as though this is some kind of
fair game is that oh yes you know we get
rid of american history that's fine
oh yeah all our revered forebears
they're bad yeah they're they're awful
oh yes no we need to have a bunch of
liberals on our conservative tv network
that's the only way it's fair uh uh
buddy
the left controls everything well why on
earth are you giving them
even one inch even one iota well because
they want unity yeah they want unity do
they
joebide wants unity huh that's why on
day one in office he eliminates
the legal recognition of sexual
difference
difference between men and women
obliterates girls bathrooms at least by
executive order
practically probably won't be able to be
put into effect much to his sugar in
eliminates girls sports eliminates
a government commission seeking to cast
our history in less than a terrible
awful light
he wants unity right uh i don't think so
there is some hope in our politics
and actually it's not it's not just
purely partisan
it's not just purely republicans good
democrats bad democrats almost always
bad in our public life but republicans
not so great either
a lot of the time however there is an
exception here to this dichotomy
tulsi gabbard you know
the conservatives for a long time now
have said very nice things about tulsi
gabbard they've sort of fallen in love
with her i think in part
as you can see from the online
commentary it's because she's very
good-looking very beautiful woman and so
some of that affects it but but a lot of
the reason conservatives have liked her
is because she's broken with her party
on certain issues and i have been
a little reticent i've been a little
reluctant
to totally get on board the tulsi train
i've liked a lot of things she said
but i've been fooled once i've been
fooled twice i have had my heart broken
by democratic politicians who i thought
were trying to change things
a little bit so i've held out but i have
to tell you tulsi gabbard
is coming out and showing that she has
if not perfect moral clarity
at least extraordinary political clarity
the mob that stormed the capital on
january 6
to try to stop congress from carrying
out its constitutional responsibilities
were behaving like domestic enemies of
our country
but let's be clear the john brennans
adam schiff's and the oligarchs in big
tech who are trying to undermine our
constitutionally protected rights
and turn our country into a police state
with kgb style surveillance
are also domestic enemies and much more
powerful
and therefore dangerous than the mob
that stormed the capital
be still my beating heart oh my gosh
because she she begins this clip
in a way that you think okay here we go
there's another one yeah the capital
thing it was the worst thing that's ever
happened it's worse than pearl harbor
right
that's how she begins to but no she says
yeah the capital thing was very bad
i think we agree with that right i think
we all basically agree
but what the
liberal dominant regime what this blob
with this wicked corrupt rotten
establishment
is doing is not only just as bad
but because they're so much more
powerful because it's so much more
vast and it penetrates so much deeper
into society
it's much much more dangerous
than what we saw at the capitol
absolutely
100 correct she is seeing something
that i would say probably most elected
republicans
aren't seeing and then tulsi gives her
evidence
john brennan said so i know looking
forward that the members of the the
biden team who have been nominated or
have been appointed
are now moving in laser-like fashion to
try to uncover as much they can about
what looks very similar to insurgency
movements that we've seen overseas
where they germinate in different parts
of the country and they gain strength
and it brings together an unholy
alliance frequently
of religious religious extremists
authoritarians
fascists bigots racists nativists
even libertarians now president biden
i call upon you and all members of
congress from both
parties to denounce these efforts by the
likes of brennan and others to take away
our civil liberties
that are endowed to us by our creator
and guaranteed in our constitution
if you don't stand up to these people
now
then our country will be in great peril
that speech that clarity
that tulsi gabbard is exhibiting
has knocked away my reticence my
reluctance she's still not a
you know perfect politician but
goodness gracious does she see something
goodness gracious that's leadership
and it's it's not even just this kind of
cheap thing where you know a
democrat becomes a republican and we all
point to her and say oh she's my
favorite democrat or something
because she's not really becoming a
republican it's something a little bit
different than that
she's pointing out the blob she's
pointing out that corrupt establishment
i love
actually in that clip she plays from
john brennan the
to talk about the swampiest of the swamp
creatures deep stadius of the deep state
creatures
john i believe he also voted for a
communist for president once seriously
and again actual communist candidate for
president
john brennan uh comes out
and he says look we're seeing in the
united states
a kind of dissident movement that we've
seen in the
dissident movements in other countries
that try to destabilize the regime
now pause for a second
when john brennan and his fellow
travelers see dissident movements in
other places
they usually say they're really great
usually they love them they kind of
encourage these dissident movements but
they certainly don't encourage dissident
movements
in the united states and did you hear
what he refers to as the dissident
movement so he
the classic he castigates americans as
racists and bigots and
the nativist well hold on that's a
little different nativist
really there you're just saying maybe we
should reduce immigration
now we let like two million people in a
year we have the most
broad open borders immigration regime in
the history of the world
maybe we should bring that down 60
percent of americans according to at
least one harvard harris poll
think that we should do that that we
should the majority of americans believe
we should we should bring
immigration including legal immigration
down substantially sold a nativist what
so you just don't want open borders and
then
libertarians libertarians now look i
mean i'm
happy to knock the libertarians just as
much as anybody but that is your example
of a hateful awful terrible group
libertarians by the way this just
underscores my point that i often make
to libertarians which is you're never
going to get the left to like you they
hate you and they think you're a
neo-nazi so
stop trying to suck up to the left but
that's what they mean these guys who who
sort of
run the blob they're figures in the
dominant liberal regime
they they might love dissident movements
abroad they don't like the dissident
movements here at home
anything that challenges their
established
power which is why they are undertaking
this
radical program with joe biden as their
vessel good old moderate scranton joe as
the vessel of this extraordinarily
radical program
to undermine the very foundations of the
country
undermine our framing of american
history how we understand ourselves
and it's no coincidence that biden is
undertaking this radical sexual policy
in his first days in office all the
transgender bills to undermine
even human nature itself to push forward
this progressive agenda that seeks to
revolutionize not just our country but
human nature itself
that is a very scary project we should
welcome any support we can from any
corners we can
even tulsi gabriel even a democrat
to to undermine that effort to stand a
thwart
that history that historicism that that
theory of progress and yell
stop i'm michael nolis the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the matt
well show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you
your family our country not just
politics but culture faith
current events all the fundamentals if
they matter to you come check out the
show